you build all this stuff right yeah most
of it NASA builds some of it I have
people yeah but you're making a joke but
it wasn't your father a NASA see my dad
had my dad does that's why in a sense
that statement was true my dad did build
me some things and he did work in NASA
so a lot of stuff was built from NASA
yeah I had a helmet that had these these
little NASCARs that go around it so if
you can't go to an Oscar I should wear
this home so you feel like you're at the
race it was stupid but my dad's like oh
I can make that
um really so he made a lot of a lot of
props so did people ever walk into his
office at Nasa
this is nice
it's got hot wheels and a little track
what planet is this for is this for the
shuttle what is it for the sky lab what
is this yeah did he work on the shuttle
yeah he worked on on Skylab and Apollo
and all that yeah he was he yeah very
big my dad was very cool he built um uh
we trained them to drive the on the moon
the the the the the
lunar module he trained them to yeah
there was a simulator so he would train
them to the Ashes to ride in the on the
moon which apparently they didn't but my
dad would beat somebody up right now if
they said they didn't go to the moon but
uh
the thing that I thought was most cool
was when they when they when they
piggyback the shuttle on top of the 747
and and had to oh okay I went out on the
roof to watch that come in here right so
here's the cool I think cool thing as
far as engineering and Logistics and all
that go is not only did they have to
figure out a way to get the shuttle and
the weight and the whole thing of the
idea of putting it on top of another
airplane right they've never done that
right so these Engineers sat in the room
like what do we got to do we got to
figure out a way to to get it to land so
someone said well how about we we have
to get it up in the air and someone said
how about we just put it on the back of
a 747 and release it
off the 747 and then we can know if it
lands or not and like that's cool
to me right so you're like you know I'm
trying to build a walker with a dildo on
it with duct tape and that's hard enough
but this you know to have a room full of
Engineers go
well first of all how do we get the
weight and then when you how do you get
the clamps they built these clamps my
dad used to come home and say I'm
working on this clamp idea to hold the
shuttle to see your dad working at the
dining room table and you working at the
same time the dildo and the clamps yeah
it sounds like the same kind of how they
did that it's unreal because they had
because it went once not only did you
get it to stay on there but when they
when they released it that had to that
had to not crash into the other like how
do they know how that work they'd
release you couldn't release a tampon
and it had landed and of course they all
you know had a big party and and got
drunk and said we did it but I remember
when my dad he was so stressed out about
that when he came home he said I can't
believe that um it was a success and we
we did it we we got it to go off in
London successfully yeah it was cool a
kid from Florida watching I remember
growing up the space program was always
I'm Canadian yeah the space program was
huge and there was everybody who worked
on it including the the astronauts but
all the people behind the scenes and at
Ground Control and and all the engineers
I mean they're that's heroic that's cool
it's cool he didn't think it was cool
when I was a kid oh yeah no I didn't
want to go to a launch I wanted to watch
The Brady Bunch or Partridge Family or
something somebody has like you're going
to a launch and on top of the VAB I
don't want to go to this crap
um didn't other kids say how cool it was
like to say that your dad works well
yeah maybe looking back on uh maybe but
I I mean I didn't think it wasn't cool I
just didn't get it I was like okay it
works at Nasa I didn't understand really
until I met when I met the astronauts
and kind of that was kind of a rock star
moment we went to see uh John Young and
Bill Bob Crippen the two the first two
guys that went up in the shuttle and my
dad says we're gonna go meet the
astronauts they're going to take the
shuttle up so I was like oh that wow
okay it was like meeting you know Prince
and it was like wow I get to meet these
are real celebrities and
it was funny because we get there and uh
there's there's like this big field you
know where the Vib and all that stuff is
where there was the Vehicle Assembly
Building where they build the shuttle
and all this stuff stores in so this big
building all the Hall of NASA but that's
where the launch pad there's like this
grass field and they had these tents for
hot dogs and food and beer and so my dad
says um
what do you want I said I don't have a
hot dog and a coke my dad looks at the
line for the hot dog and Coke line was
like 50 people deep and the line for the
beer was like one person so my dad says
you're gonna you're gonna have a beer
and how old are you like 13. and I
remember saying okay and so I'm just I'm
just like okay so he said don't tell
your mother at first he looked at me he
said he's like how is it I said I don't
like it and well don't tell your mother
and I don't remember if I had one two
sips but I remember it was like it was
like three rockets going off you know
just like I was so plastered I didn't
even know and I came home my mom's like
how was the launch I'm like I was so
drunk I don't even know I didn't
so yeah did he want you to go into uh oh
yeah there's a whole bit in my show or
you're gonna be a you're going to work
at Nasa like me I'm like yeah it's me
because my brother went to the Air Force
Academy and was an F-16 fighter jet
pilot your brother yeah and so I do a
whole thing in the show with slides
where I say my dad worked at Nasa and
built rockets and my brother went to the
Air Force Academy and then there's me
and it does this whole in a black sheep
of the family song and as a picture of
me in an ATT commercial I'm like this
you know dorky and uh I do a whole story
about yes and my whole adopted life I
really wanted to be a comedian I tell
the whole story about trying to get into
comedy
foreign
[Music]